well Philadelphia's prosecutor is
considered a national role model for
criminal justice reform despite
criticism of his progressive agenda
district attorney Larry Krasner made it
a priority to investigate problematic
convictions when he took office last
year in just 19 months nine people some
serving life sentences have been
exonerated he also fired 31 people to
clean up the DA's office national
correspondent Jerry Cadogan talked to
him about reforming the culture she also
met three men who were recently
exonerated Jericka what was it like
hearing their stories
Maria Elena it was very powerful I spoke
with three men who together spent nearly
74 years in prison for crimes they say
they did not commit in some cases
prosecutors or police knew the entire
time that they were innocent and did
nothing well now a progressive District
Attorney is changing that and as we
learned those who are benefiting from
those changes are in disbelief that
they're finally free I spent 27 years
and 11 months in prison I did twenty-one
years five months five days I spent
approximately 24 years in prison
before the night was over I was being
charged with murder Chester Holman I was
a juvenile lifer Terrence Lewis I
initially turned myself in sue and
Johnny berry have always maintained
their innocence and now the court system
agrees overturning their convictions for
second-degree murder robbery and
conspiracy all of them now in their 40s
have been exonerated physically I'm free
but like there's just a lot of emotional
things that I'm dealing with trying to
find myself in July a judge Freeh
Chester Holman after prosecutors
reopened his case and proved he was
innocent of the 1993 murder for which he
was serving life in prison authorities
always had evidence that pointed to
other suspects but that evidence was not
disclosed at the time of his conviction
each day has gotten stronger and I'm
better Johnny what has this been like
for you well today marks the one-year
anniversary of me being home Wow I'm
still learning how to be free
honest with you it's a learning process
personally I haven't been home not even
ninety days although I've been happy and
I'm grateful is it's definitely been
difficult I have been enslaved mentally
as well as physically I'm still
traumatized this fell upon us they
uprooted our life and when I say they
meaning the system as a whole we really
have to do it with statistics
Philadelphia's district attorney Larry
Krasner wants to correct those wrongs
the oath is to seek justice when
somebody sits in a jail cell for a crime
they did not commit that is an injustice
the former public defender assumed the
top prosecutor job in 2018
[Applause]
one of his first missions beefed up the
conviction Integrity Unit to investigate
legitimate claims of wrongful
convictions there was a culture at
various times of win at all costs and if
that meant that you were gonna take the
document that suggested there was a
different suspect a document that the
Constitution requires you as a
prosecutor to turn over to the defense
and you were gonna shred it he did and
then there was a separate issue with
certain detectives and everybody who was
in the system knew about it
in his first week in office he'd fired
31 employees I did not enjoy it but it
was necessary to do especially as I see
these exonerations happen and guess
whose names just keep coming up for
having been involved in convictions of
innocent people the people you let go
yep that story will be developing stay
tuned what do you say about those ex
prosecutors who still believe that the
people who've been exonerated are guilty
I don't think this is the realm of
belief I think we should be working with
facts the system will always make
mistakes but the kind of prosecutor who
is willing to do these things that are
illegal and unconstitutional in order to
have a win is the kind of prosecutor
who's going to say to you
I still believe they're guilty because
they're covering their own tracks the
straight shooter also says he's
determined not to waste court time jail
space or tax dollars on prosecuting
low-level offenses like marijuana
possession or petty theft but when it
comes to those issues Krasner's critics
say he's releasing
criminals that are likely to commit
another crime for judges who think or
have said you've gone rogue and that
you're a group of renegades how do you
respond to that well first of all I have
huge respect for the judiciary is a
small portion among them who I think
take this personally
when when we say what we say and we're
very direct about it that these policies
and the people who were in the DA's
office caused mass incarceration as for
the conviction Integrity Unit it's
reviewed about 200 cases since krasner
took office conviction Integrity is a
particularly sticky situation because
you are looking back on things that
happened in the past and sometimes
you're asking the same judge who has
already said no to overturning this
conviction to turn it over now based
upon additional information 80 Sundays
ago I was condemned to die in jail that
was my reality John are you ok yeah
there are people still remain behind the
walls that are actually innocent when
you're innocent and you run across
another individual that's innocent your
soul it's a connection these are my
brothers here and I still got brothers
that remain behind the wall in the
hearse and while it does hurt the men
say they are not angry district attorney
Krasner told us the conviction Integrity
Unit actually rejects most of the cases
it investigates so far it's overturned
convictions and only about 4% of the
cases that they're looking into but he
you know campaigned on this got 75% of
the vote and said that he wanted to put
more resources to this because you look
at a system like the criminal justice
system not in just Philadelphia but
across the country and it's broken part
of justice is correcting injustice the
wrong persons behind bars do something
about it and it's a wonderful program
yeah it's an impressive program that's
what more days do that across the
country absolutely Sarika thank you very
much you can hear more of jury cos
conversation with Philadelphia district
attorney Larry crasner on today's CBS
this morning podcast you can listen
wherever you like to get your podcast